hey guys welcome to another episode of
my flippin two billion series today
we're starting off at about 94 mil we're
just about to break the 100 mil mark a
so we're gonna start off today with some
random boots we're gonna try for a
hundred of them had a pretty good margin
on them so leave that in there for now
another guy want to try a secret
longsword they don't come through very
quick but they actually have a pretty
good margin since they are pretty new as
an item so the margin tends to be a bit
higher than the older ones I've gone for
149 and we can sell them for 139 that's
a 10k margin that's very good for an
item like this we'll go ahead and do
another 100 these guys I think as well
next up I was looking at the abyssal
dagger P plus plus I've tried this item
and think once before it didn't work out
so well but the seems to be fluctuating
up and down quite a bit so we'll give it
another try
abyssal dagger P plus plus maybe will go
for I have five or six of these find
them for 6,200 and you will do five and
the last up we're gonna do some dragon
darts and that will be pretty well it
okay nevermind we're gonna put one
offering for some raw monkfish how about
the ten GP margin on it yeah so well
let's put 20 km so far believe this in
overnight at 26 actually will that be
enough and perfect that's all our money
okay this is a terrible flip I messed up
on a couple different things to start
off here the dragon darts we lost 587 K
on incidentally I think we lost about
the same on the draconic village didn't
work out with lost probably a mill while
he didn't make about tuner K off of the
boots does not offset our one point one
no loss pretty well um but you know
happens sometimes
okay next up we're going to try the
third age plate legs this is a really
expensive flip but never tried it before
so I'll give it a whirl looks like a 1.2
mil profit on G tracker
next up rent rise them two rocks plate
legs 851 K and a last step we're going
to do some air orbs and we'll do a 19 K
of them which we'll use up all of our
money so hopefully these flips will pan
out a little bit better than the last
ones and we'll bump it up to 20 K
alright we'll come back in a while so
unfortunately one of my clips corrupted
that but we're actually up to at 98.7
notes pretty close to 99
and now what that money is from mostly
is an air or flip we flipped the rocks I
believe and some ropes of darkness and
33 granite boots which actually gave us
another hefty profit of like 600 K I
believe and just a couple other things
that when I was actually doing on my
laptop including some high volume clips
but anyway the rest of this episode she
was less messy that was just a bit of a
mistake yeah so we're gonna hit up now
the ring of stone for about two mil and
65k roughly and hopefully we can sell it
for maybe a tunic a profit and probably
try for maybe we'll try for 10
next up the band of ste Hyde boot seems
like has a pretty nice margin on there
right now for how much cost we'll go
ahead and do 20 of these guys and an
interesting thing I've never tried
before see bones - peaches tab we're
gonna try buying them for just under 800
and we'll put in a hefty amount of these
I'm saying maybe 20 to 30 K these guys
excessive decent margin and they seem to
be pretty low right now so try for 30 K
these guys next up I'm think of trying
to inky top well kind of put an offer
and hopefully we can snipe it for a low
I don't really expect him to come
through but I have in the past got like
a three mil margin item like this just
because I had an offering and nobody
else did pretty well so maybe try just
under 24 mil 2,300 and we'll put one in
for now and last up the granite
longsword once again we're gonna try for
both hey 13k margin and we'll just dump
the rest of our money in here we'll
probably hit pretty close to the buying
limit around 75 all right we'll be back
in a while
so we've quite a few of the benzos di
boots coming through as well as the
ground longswords but surprisingly we
actually got a good amount of money from
the bones - peaches tabs got an 82 GP
margin on them I given us 869 came total
you put in some black chin Champa so
it's just lost us 90 KS in the report
there but the Bandos di boots
so far I've never does he under came
profit we still have another two to sell
and we do have the ring of stone and
grant longswords selling okay so I
actually ended up selling off the rest
of the items and look at that bringing
us to a hundred and 1.9 million to mils
we finally surpassed Under
now the grant longswords actually gave
us a 1.1 milk profit and the ring of
stones gave us about a 500 K profit so
we're going to jump right into another
flip here we're gonna do Ranger clubs
this time 27:25 and we'll do ten of them
next step we're looking at the crows
armor set and has a decent margin on it
for how quick this item sells but I
don't expect to get more than thirty or
forty K on this but we'll give it a shot
try buying it for twenty one twenty
seven and we'll do eight of the krills
next up we're gonna do a page
combination flip we're gonna do it with
the our middle page and I turn it into
the book of law I believe split offering
for I think twenty of each page and
there we go all of the page offers are
in and last steps the dragon dart looks
like as a pretty good margin that right
now hundred GP which is amazing and
we'll do what we'll do 13 K since that
will be pretty much all our money
invested at that point thirteen thousand
what we have enough I have a leaf soap
confirm and there we go
come back in a little while okay so this
will have pretty much everything as the
curls armor sets we're pretty good
actually a 78 K margin given this 624
came profit on that not bad
the Rangers gloves were the best we have
a hundred and thirty-five kh1 and 10 of
those giving us just about 1.3 mil in
profit the dragons are expended up
losing a little bit money on the book of
laws are looking really good right now
to put a hundred K profit however we're
only able to sell I think three of them
so far the rest were still hoping itself
for a fifty K profit that's not terrible
but hopefully they'll sell off soon ok
we're actually able to sell nine of them
so far so we'll drop the last 11 in for
about 1115 so even trying to sell them
for a while now so hopefully these will
actually sell off now an item I've been
wanting to try for a while is the
ancient wyvern shield a very expensive
item actually upwards of 30 mil right
now so we'll try buying them for thirty
to fifty one and I think I'm gonna put
an offering for two of them and that
we're gonna try dragging darts again
even though we keep breaking even but
the emergent is like 100 right now so
well we'll see if it works out okay we
sold off everything now the book of law
page set was a little convoluted but in
total we ended up profiting 960 K off
that item so pretty good although we did
lose about a millon profit just because
we couldn't actual
sell them off quickly enough we were
looking to make actually a 2.5 ml off
that flip I've only a mil still pretty
good the wyvern Shields came in as well
we profited 898 K on those and that we
ended up dumping the darts didn't end up
coming through so how much money are we
at now let's go claim the last offer in
there the book Allah page set bringing
us up to a hundred and six mil as a
pretty good brew finally a crested the
hundred mil mark hopefully it will speed
up from here now this wasn't actually a
ton of flips but we ended up actually
making about 10 million profit this
episode yeah I hope you guys enjoyed if
you are enjoying the series don't forget
to toss it alight always helps out and I
will see you guys in episode number six